Lastly we're here to help. When you work in the class you will never be alone.
There is a wiki with lots of useful information about the content of the
course. There is also a link to the syllabus, or what we call the green sheet,
that was e-mailed to you. If you can't find something in the wiki, search the
forum, or add your own question to the forum. I'll be reading the forums, but
other students will be there to help you as well. When using the forums,
remember not to post working solutions to the problems. If the forum can't help
you, you can live chat with a Udacity employee, who is, an expert on the course
content and logistics. You can contact them using the blue rectangle in the
lower-right. Now dive in and enjoy the class. I'm looking forward to working
and learning with you.